he has a very pithy elegant and
economic in terms of use of words to the
point way of explaining how we learn
languages hi there steve kaufman here
and today i want to announce my live
stream conversation with dr stephen
krashen
remember if you enjoy these videos
please subscribe click on the bell for
notifications
i'm really excited i've known dr krashen
for quite a few years
i met him for the first time in taiwan
and uh so this i can't remember how many
years ago it was maybe 15 20 years ago i
didn't know who he was i attended a
language conference in taiwan he gave a
talk there
and
i was just so struck by how
elegant how simple and how accurate his
description was of the process of
language acquisition
and prior to that of course
i had learned languages i had been
interested enough in languages to start
up link
i'd done a lot of research
so i had not only my own experience of
learning languages
but you know i'm going to show you in a
while here all the different books that
i bought on the subject because i like
buying books
and there's so much complicated theory
within this whole idea of language
instruction
and language learning and all of a
sudden
krashen
dr krashen he presented
uh you know and i bought this book in
taiwan it's a very thin book but it has
it all there the stages of language
acquisition and it was it was clear it
was like the gordian knot it was like
occam's razor it was a simple
explanation of how we learned languages
it cut through all the other stuff
i don't want to get too much into
dr krashen's explanation of the theory
of language acquisition
because
we're going to have a live stream you
can see a link in the description box
where you can reserve your spot and
participate and ask questions
dr krashen is very transparent you can
go to his website
i think it's scratching.com and there's
a lot of free material available there
but as you know he he stresses the fact
that we learn through input we learn
through compelling comprehensible input
we learn through meaningful messages and
some people may claim that that's not
the whole story that we also have to
speak
and that some people can read and and
can can uh you know have high
comprehension but are afraid to speak
but if people are afraid to speak
they're going to be even more afraid if
they don't understand so i just feel
that everything he said about language
acquisition
matched my experience in learning the
languages that i learned throughout my
first my professional career and then
when i got more interested in languages
and when i got very interested in
learning languages you know as a sort of
my third career to start to focus in on
that
i did
study online and of course in bookstores
when you know 20 years ago wasn't that
common to find stuff online so i just
want to show you
you know so i bought a book a short
history of linguistics well that's not
quite language learning
uh english as a second language in the
mainstream
teaching learning and identity like
people just want to learn languages
phrases and idioms you know i'm talking
about this don't try to master phrases
and idioms
uh but let's see then i even bought a
swedish book here les apollo fremontes
broke
how languages are learned and on and on
you know and uh the practice of english
language teaching
and there was a lot of stuff there that
was quite complicated got into you know
different types of learners kinetic
learners oral learners visual learners
all of which is not true of course
i understood very early on that the key
sort of again call it the gordian not
for measuring where we are in a language
is how many words we know
words are key
with words you get the rest of it you
get the grammar everything flows from
having words and yet and so there are
many books on learning vocabulary in
another language and yet it all boils
down here again vocabulary
description acquisition and pedagogy it
goes vocabulary and language teaching i
read through all these books and yet it
really boils down to what krashen says
read and listen get the language in you
get the brain used to the language
acquire words naturally if you do all of
these things at some point you're going
to want to speak it doesn't matter when
that point is of course you can't be
intimidated but the better your level of
comprehension the more words you have at
your disposal the greater likelihood
that you won't be so intimidated
so and i i not only is stephen krashan
astute in his
analysis and research this is based on
research into how we acquire languages
but he has a very pithy elegant
and
economic in terms of use of words to the
point way of explaining how we learn
languages so people are going to pick
holes in some of the things that he says
people are going to have different
points of view and we welcome different
points of view and so please join us for
this live stream whether it is to
support what dr krashen has to say
whether it be to attack me which is fine
i don't mind it i love it
or whether uh to agree with what we have
to say or share your experience of
language learning with us you're more
than welcome to participate we're going
to have a conversation where we're going
to talk about our experience of language
learning and and talking to people who
are involved in language learning i
think it's going to be really
interesting i'm very much looking
forward to it so
please reserve your spot it's going to
be on youtube as well as live streamed
so thank you and i look forward to
seeing you bye for now